io tolgo quelle brutte
ragazzi benvenuti a 1 la puntata di
cucina buttata nel leggere che cosa
anche io grazie tu che mi sta guardando
a casa quanto ti sta rompendo i [ __ ]
st domenica tanto chi s'è rotto i
[ __ ] più di te
[Musica]
oggi facciamo uova di pasqua
a coniglietto
1 al latte e uno bianco
ritiene di tiramisù
allora ragazzi io intanto vado a
preparare la mia bagna
bagna una ryan ve lo ricordate
dall'altra volta che cos'è la bagno ma
ryan
bravissimo del
cioccolato allora mi metto intanto a
spezzettare il cioccolato che una delle
cose più piacevoli in assoluto che si
possa fare nella vita
[Musica]
io vado intanto è brutto
sentire
ogni tanto vado a 50 gradi e quindi un
50 gradi no no no no no no no no sono
già fuori
no allora ragazzi a questo punto io mi
ha vantaggio con altre preparazioni
lascia un attimo quelli lì a
raffreddarsi nel frattempo il 78 di giro
però vorrei andare avanti con altra roba
quindi crema al mascarpone e ripieno
tiramisù perché qua né che fanno le cose
[Musica]
salutari capito uovo di seitan
questa pasqua da però per la mia ricetta
facciamo un pochino di modifiche come
funziona il caffè solubile io me lo
invento è
man mano assaggiare il fatto che odia il
caffè quindi se mi farà schifo sarà
fatto bene posso solo usare questo qui
per misurare perché non ho
male leggero come caffè capito non
interdittivo allora no
per assaggiarlo devo essere userò un
altro misurino
molto leggero forse di più
praga leggero ci sta che sia leggero
cioè beverino comunque vorrei un attimo
dirvi che per fare questa ricetta avrete
bisogno di uno spruzzino quindi
prendetelo apritelo
deliziosa questo lo spruzzino no molto
carino delizioso e a questo punto
andiamo a versarci dentro
fallimento noi veniamo da un fallimento
legato alle uova di pasqua cocente
facciamo andare un secondo rvm
una rimarrà per sempre così
e questo è l'effetto finale
io quest'anno deciso non solo che
celavano parlo bene ma che ne faccio
pure ripiene e sa cosa difficile che il
processo di oggi è molto tecnico noi non
abbiamo tecnica non sono precisi
facciamo kacar e quindi di base ho
bisogno veramente di molta molta
attenzione e serietà ragazzi questa è la
mia tecnica gli ultimi se lo faccio
sempre con le campagnole perché secondo
me rimangono un pochino più
indietro uno spazzolone invece le
campagnoli mi tengono
sì mi tengono la cottura grazie enrico
non riesco a finire
la frase
andiamo abbattiamo battiamo battiamo noi
se facessimo un cheesecake ragazzi
andiamo a separare adesso gli albumi dai
tuorli facciamo 8 uova perché ci servirà
un botto di crema ragazzi allora ragazzi
questa qui è una delle cose che in
cucina mi piace di più in assoluto
quando ero piccolo mia nonna aveva
proprio quelle piccola manuela un olio
di gomiti assurdo assurdo lo zucchero
ragazzi questo è un altro momento che
amavo io facevo prima così sempre e poi
cosa fondamentale raga quando avete le
fruste deve diventa praticamente bianco
da vabbè bellissimo ragazzi unire le
uova allo zucchero è una cosa che può
solamente guidare bei ricordi
aggiungiamo mascarpone
nava bei ragazzi bellissimo ma è tutto
bellissimo
questa ricetta mi piace tantissimo
questa parte della ricetta posso dirlo
ma qui c'è un qualcosa di molto
importante da fare ragazzi un qualcosa
che tutti quelli nati nella mia
generazione conoscono che è incorporare
gli albumi
bravissimo dal basso persona tanto
capito perché così almeno si non si
smontano gli album io sta cosa non l'ho
capita io non ho fatto una crema
io ho fatto una nuvola qualcosa già meno
volatile
è una nuvola allora torniamo un attimo
quindi a questo punto alle nostre uova
paga la gara che ha raggiunto la
temperatura 27 gradi 27 gradi questo qui
27 gradi ora bisognerà farlo risalire al
volo a 31 allora qui abbiamo le nostre
formine le vedete che carine
bellissimo allora adesso andiamo col
dietro subito
mettiamoci a lavorare il cioccolato per
bene ovunque lo facciamo nero ovunque
non accendere ovunque questo è quello
che si fa vedi con l'eccesso come veri
mettere la cioccolati questi stampi sono
bellissimi ragazzi tra parentesi se
conoscete qualcuno che fa stampi
rimandate di tipo tutti strani che
vogliamo fare tutte torte ormai assurde
allora a sto punto quello che vorrei
fare è il musetto farlo diverso
prendiamo cioccolato bianco e con la
massima precisione
però bisogno dell'aiuto di uno di voi
ragazze questi qui livaja portare bene
in frigo di piazze così e li lasciamo
raffreddare al volo prima di coprirli è
chiaro quello che voglio fare no ok
ragazzi è reato il momento di un po di
porno anche per chi ama invece la roba
più vanilla
ok ragazzi vedete intanto ho fatto
questo adesso io cosa faccio qui dove di
sé un pochino cristallizzato qui il
cazzo a questo qui graziano e avrò
bisogno che tu mi faccio un pochino la
staffetta senti e portami gli altri i
fratellini ma e allora ragazze a questo
punto
invertiamo i due cioccolati sul nero al
bianco su bianco e nero io vado a fare
intanto un secondo strato ovunque mamma
mia ragazzi che bruciò di culo che sta
ricetta adesso succede una magia io vado
a fare la stessa cosa di prima vedete in
giro lo faccio bello proprio ma al volo
ci infilo i biscotti in modo da farli
entrare nel cioccolato
lo vedi quello che ancora è
chiaro adesso però che cosa faccio una
cosa pazzesca l'armatura
un pochino al volo ragazzi
spruzzino capisci
ormai questa qui è alta pasticceria tu
che dici
vado a metterli in freezer comunque
siete un po cioè allora ragazzi siamo
tornati un'ora dopo io ho paura ve lo
dico proprio
andiamo ad aggiungere ragazzi il nostro
la nostra crema al mascarpone o
possiamo mettere in freezer che si
addensa dopo tutto sto lavoro ma la
prossima volta non possiamo far
spaghetto aglio olio questi qua come
potete vedere hanno un bug
ma è un delizioso però quindi io
prenderò questo cioccolato lo piazzano
sul bordo
enrico ho capito che deve essere veloce
però fare il culo c'è un momento di
attenzione partiti tutti
eccolo qui
[Musica]
dietro mi dispiace
mai
almeno questo è il tipico ragazzo un po
bruttino ma che nasconde un cuore d'oro
posso una bella croccantezza posso dire
è per collocamento
ma legge vigente è un po gelato dedicato
sensibili
brutto in culo ma può culo quindi che
cosa dobbiamo dire quest'anno vi
prendete metà del nuovo già pagato
qualcosa senza che voi fate da soli ma
la riempite di tiramisù pazzesco ragazzi
siamo arrivati alla prima di questo
video mi raccomando se farete l'uovo di
pasqua al tiramisù pagatemi su instagram
detto ciò che ci vedremo domenica alle
12 un nuovo video su cui sono mutati
ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]